a police officer who mistakenly shot and
killed a black man at an Alabama mall
will not be charged protesters burned
American flags last night outside City
Hall in Hoover
black lives don't matter was painted on
the flags EJ Bradford jr. was killed on
Thanksgiving night
Matea vo reales in hoover that's south
of Birmingham with details of the State
Attorney General's decision today a lot
of people upset about this one good
morning to you
that's exactly right Gail good morning
to you as well this two-month
investigation involved a lot of
witnesses and a lot of evidence
including some disturbing surveillance
video that you are about to see right
now
Bradford's family continues to call the
death of their son murder and says this
investigation is just an attempt to
cover up responsibility to fee you know
bad they are justifying shooting my son
three times how was it justifiable you
Mantic Bradford and April Pipkin say
they want justice for the death of their
son DJ newly released surveillance video
from the Alabama mall shows the moment
shoppers scatter at the sound of
gunshots Bradford is then seen running
toward the direction of the gunfire
holding a licensed handgun of his own
a moment later from behind Bradford a
responding Hoover officer shoots and
kills him believing he's the suspect
responsible according to the Attorney
General
Bradford's family says he was trying to
protect those around him you watched the
video I didn't like it because it's
murder
I saw was going back to help his friend
a 24 page report released by Alabama's
Attorney General concludes the unnamed
officer who shot Bradford reasonably
exercised his official duties during the
three-second encounter the Bradford
family's attorney Benjamin Crump plans
to file a civil suit against the city of
Hoover the police
officer in less than two seconds made a
judgment call that he saw a black man he
saw a good he concluded that he's a
criminal
any shot in the back the city of Hoover
never released any information on the
officer involved or his background but
they do plan to release a statement
about this investigation later today the
FBI says there was not enough evidence
to open up a civil rights investigation
still right now the family is calling
for all of the surveillance video
collected by investigators to be
released they also plan to march to the
attorney general's office in montgomery
later today to demand and their answers
Norah got a feel for the family Maria
thank you